- On this episode,
I bring it to London.
(audience cheers)
(upbeat hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee show.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 193
of the #AskGaryVee show.
(audience cheers)
Louder.
(crowd roars)
Let's go.
Let's go London.
We are in London. Big shout
right from the get for IBM.
Hosting us down here.
We are wework an
amazing company.
Thrilled to be here.
We are part of the wework family
at VaynerMedia in San Francisco
and on April 1st
VaynerMedia is coming to London.
(audience roars)
So excited about this before we
get into the show, DRock,
one, we probably
should've brought India.
That was a mistake.
And two, we will at some point
have to have some conversations
after we're done with the show
with a bunch of you because
I'm very excited now
that we are in London
I've decided that it's
time for me to actually cheer
for properly a football team
outside of the New York Jets.
(crowd woos)
(crowd discussion starts)
Relax, relax, relax.
London, let me give
you my criteria.
Here's my criteria:
Number one, they have
not won anything for
25 years or more.
(crowd yelling)
Number two, number two.
Number two,
they need to have an all time
devastating loss that I have to
watch with my own eyes.
(crowd murmurs)
We'll do that later.
Actually that'll probably be
the question of the day,
what football team
should I cheer for?
All right so I think it's
time to get into the show.
I'm very excited so I think
were going to much like we did
episode 100. DRock,
we (censored) this up.
This should have
been episode 200.
Should have hustled
a little bit more.
Maybe if you didn't miss
your flight to Australia.
(audience laughter)
Let's do it. Who wants
the first question?
- [Organizer] We've got
a mic up around here.
- Where are we?
Beautiful.
Anybody?
See that man right there.
DRock, you zoom it in.
Love it.
What is your name, my friend?
- (inaudible)
- [Gary] How are you?
- Very well thanks.
- [Gary] Good.
- [Man] How about yourself?
- [Gary] Tremendous.
What's your question?
- [Man] My question is I work in
podcasting and its a media that
has been settling on the
cusp of being mainstream
but never completely there.
How would you go about turning
not even a podcast but any idea
from just below
awareness of mainstream
content into being
a mainstream media.
- [Gary] How would I turn
podcasting itself
into mainstream culture?
- [Man] Not that specifically
if you'd like.
- Or do you mean your podcast?
- [Man] No, no.
- Podcasting, yeah.
I don't think
that's a very good idea.
I don't think you go and make a
consumption platform mainstream.
I think what you do is you
reverse engineer when things go
mainstream and ride them.
To me, I have no
romance of platform.
I don't have a romance to
television or radio or mobile
devices or social networks or
podcasting or written form.
What I have romance for is your
collective attention and then
riding those platforms.
I mean look I was excited about
podcasting with Odeo years ago
and it's been funny to watch.
What's interesting about
podcasting is I think it's about
to get even far more mainstream
as we start going into the
smart-ification of cars and
Bluetooth and those functions
where people are going to be
really consuming these podcasts
at scale while they're traveling
and so for me the thought of
taking a consumption
platform mainstream is
A) way too big of a deal
to actually pull off.
B) It's pretty historic, my man.
The written word, audio
and video are the platforms.
Where they get
delivered evolves.
- [Man] Okay.
- That didn't satisfy you.
(crowd applause)
Hold on you can
leave the mic.
I don't leave money
unsatisfied customers
at least when they're live.
When you guys are watching,
I can't figure it out but while
we're still, here go ahead.
- [Man] We need more listeners.
There's hundreds of
thousands of podcasts.
- You need more listeners?
No shit you need more listeners.
Retailers need more shoppers.
Painters need more people
going to (censored) museums.
That's not for you.
- [Man] 1 in 2 people still
don't know what podcasts is.
How do you chase them?
- I wouldn't.
This is the point.
You can't force human beings to
do what you (censored) want.
What you have to respond to
what they actually (censored) do.
Got it?
(audience cheers)
I wanted in 2006,
10 years ago, for more
people to watch YouTube because
I had the only (censored) show
that was doing anything
but I couldn't force that.
I want badly that more than 14%
of money to be on e-commerce in
America 20 years after I
launched an e-commerce wine
business but I can't have that.
Got it?
-[Man] Yeah, yeah.
- What you need to do is
realize podcasting is (censored)
enormous and I have a feeling
that you're not
podcast's father.
I feel you have podcasts within
the ecosystem of podcasting
and you should recognize that
there's plenty of (censored)
attention for you to be
successful so why don't you win
over the people that are
actually there than worrying
about everyone to get on it.
- [Man] (inaudible)
(audience laughter)
- I love it.
Let's move.
- [Man] Thank you.
- You got it, brother.
Let's move.
Who's got a question?
What you think DRock?
That was good.
I thought I was strong there.
- [Man 2] Hey Gary.
(inaudible) from yesterday.
- How are you?
Good to see you.
Thanks for coming last night.
Who made it out last
night for the meet up?
Much love.
Thank you, thank you.
- [Man 2] I would just like
to ask any advice for myself?
I'm 19 years old.
- Yes.
- [Man 2] Trying to make
it in the business world.
What would be your
advice to people my age?
- Well I mean (censored).
(audience laughter)
A lot.
I think the number one
piece of advice that I have for
19-year-old is always patience.
I think for a lot of us
here most of us, not everybody,
there's some youngsters in the
crowd, but we've all been there
and I think the impatience so
many of us have at 19 tends to
be the detrimental
aspect of our personality.
I think there's way too much
wanting it now, now, now which
then leads to very short-term
behavior and I was say to a lot
of my friends I'm like look
there's a big difference between
being rich and being wealthy if
we're talking about money within
the context of the business.
And really normally is
predicated on people that
thinking on 20 or 30 year window
versus people that are
thinking in a
20 or 30 minute window.
I've been very concerned and a
lot of you have seen this from
me because you're not here if
you don't know some of my spiel
I've been pushing very hard
against these 22 and 23-year-old
business and life coaches
who are on Instagram selling a
bullshit lifestyle and trying to
get people into their mastermind
and (censored) $800 e-books
and the reason so many of you
19-year-olds the market is
falling for it is 'cause you
want it now.
I can only speak from the advice,
I can only give advice
that I took myself.
I built a business from
three to $60 million and more
specifically from three to $25
million and a three-year window
as a kid and building a business
from three to 25 and it's yours
to then also pay myself at that
time still $40,000 a year is me
eating my own dog food.
I was patient.
I was putting everyone of those
dollars back into the business
because I knew that it
wasn't over at 26 or 28 or 32.
So many of you as you build
something are extracting dollars
out so you can buy things.
Like dumb (censored) watches and
a car and just dumb shit instead
of putting that money back
into the business because you're
building something long-term.
My number one piece of advice
of advice at 19 is one patience.
I'm still patient and
I'm old I'm (censored) 40.
And I'm old maybe not to some of
you but do you remember when you
were 19, I thought
people died at 40.
(audience laughter)
I think patience.
I think you need to understand
that you're not
entitled to shit.
I think a lot of people
at a younger age have this
fascination, and not
millennials,
when us
40-year-olds were 19.
When us 60-year-olds were 19,
there's an entitlement early on
'cause the market hasn't
punched you in the mouth yet.
Right?
People think that, especially
right now, just 'cause you start
a business doesn't mean
you're entitled to winning.
It's insanity.
Everybody thinks you just get to
say you're an entrepreneur and
then good shit happens.
The data's against you.
98% of you are going to
fail (censored) hard.
And go work for the man.
That's right.
The market says (censored) you
98 out of 100 times so why after
all of a sudden because there
was a "Social Network" the movie
and because Shark Tank and
Lion's Den and all this shit
everybody thinks
anybody can do it.
So patience, betting on your
strengths figure out who the
(censored) you are,
listen, learn and don't...
Let me promise you two things
there's no nine week
process to make money.
There's no seven figure expert
that's going to
show you the way.
It's fucking hard work.
(applause)
Let's move it. I like it.
I like how you're
running around there.
We're in the back.
And then we'll get to the front.
- [Organizer] Can I see some
hands on this side everybody?
- Back left hands, anybody
got some back left hands.
There's some.
- [Organizer] They're
making me run for it.
- [Gary] If you call
that running,
you're super
out of shape, bro.
(audience laughter)
- [Organizer] (inaudible)
- [Gary] That seem
like a super slow skip.
Hello darling.
- Hi Gary.
It's Gabrielle Goysons.
- [Gary] I know who
you are, all the time.
Good to see you, Gab.
- I've got a question
that you've never
ever been asked before.
- [Gary] Okay.
- Yeah, I do.
Bear with me.
- [Gary] Okay.
- Would you like
a special banana?
- [Gary] Yes.
- Because nobody eats
a banana like Gary.
- [Gary] Nobody.
I love it.
Let's clap it up for the banana.
Nobody, DRock.
- [Gabrielle] Also, can I
actually ask a question?
- Yes.
For a lot of you that only watch
the #AskGaryVee show this comes
from what I putting out on
Snapchat so if you're not
following follow.
- [Gabrielle] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Gabrielle] Do you
know Desert Island Disks?
- No.
(audience laughter)
- [Gabrielle] Nobody
eats a banana like Gary.
By the way, podcasts I am a
voice actor so if you want a
podcast intro, give me a shout.
- Guys this is in the fucking
biz dev with each other show.
(audience laughter)
It's the #AskGaryVee show.
- [Gabrielle] If you could only
take three apps with you which
apps would you take
to bring you joy or--
- Instagram number one because
it's soft porn and I need that.
(audience laughter)
I mean I'm going to
keep it real, right?
I didn't really hear it.
Deserted island?
- [Gabrielle] Desert
island, three apps.
- Instagram soft porn one.
Apps?
Safari so I'd have
the entire Internet.
(audience laughs)
I'd be set.
I wouldn't need
anything after that.
And probably...
- [Man 4] Grindr.
(audience laughter)
- I mean if there was only one
other dude on the island
Grindr would be right.
And I would say
probably messenger, right?
The default messenger
thing, just communication tools.
Cool thank you.
Let's do it.
Who's got a question?
(audience applause)
Grindr that was
really well done.
- [Ed] Hey Gary.
- How are you?
- Good, thanks.
- Good. Stand up, brother.
What is your name?
- Ed.
- [Gary] Ed.
- Simple question.
- [Gary] Good.
- I am very face to face
and hands on with people--
- [Gary] You are.
- You are.
- [Gary] I am, yes.
(audience laughter)
- How do you feel
about remote workers?
- I'm not into it.
Now it is a massively proven
successful way to
go about doing business.
I wish my homie Jason Fried,
the founder of 37 signals, was
sitting here he'd punch me
directly in the mouth and he
would be right because for Jason
Fried and DHH the way they built
their company or Matt Mullenweg
who's built a billion-dollar
company, Automattic Wordpress
they have built it on absolute
only remote
operators and employees.
I, for me, self-awareness,
Gary Vaynerchuk, don't like it.
I don't like having
satellite offices.
I don't like it.
I want to be very hands-on.
I'm very touchy-feely.
I scale and build my business
by walking by people's
desks and can feel their.
I literally sometimes go to the
bathroom to take a piss, right,
walk walk by somebody don't like
it way the felt and as I'm going
to take a piss text my HR
company I'm like I need to see
Rick for five minutes.
That's literally how
I built my company.
That's how I build my companies.
I'm built on EQ.
It's funny when everyone said
social media was like not human
and it's bad the reason why so
optimistic about social media or
technology is technology's a
gateway drug to human connection.
I know it because I only
live on human connection.
I just use that stuff to scale.
Without social media and
technology there wouldn't have
been one person on the corner
of that street last night,
let alone 300.
I used it to have the three and
half hours I had with all of you
last night one by one
by one because of it.
It was the enabler.
Now, remote workers can do that
but for me to be successful I
really like the idea
of having it together.
Team dynamics.
I'm a guy that loves sports.
Clearly I like team dynamics.
It's not for me.
I don't like when people work
from, we had to force people to
work from home for a year
because we're going so fast and
we ran out of space and fire
codes and everything and it was
the worst year.
I hated it.
I don't feel that people are
productive, I don't give a
(censored) what you
say I don't believe you.
(audience laughter)
And so I don't like it.
And so it's not for me as an
operator to run a company for me.
But for a lot of
people it could be great.
I will never build a company
that has remote employees
at scale ever.
It will never happen.
- [Ed] Thank you.
- Cool, you got it.
(applause)
Let's get up here.
Let's get some peeps up here.
Sorry. Yeah, get over here.
Great running bro.
- Nice to see you.
It's Daniel Presley.
The book Thank You Economy was
so focused on other people and
listening and going
through people's twitter feed.
Finding stuff they're interested
in, responding to that.
- [Gary] Yes.
- You've now evolved to a
book called #AskGaryVee,--
- [Gary] Yes.
- and it's very much your show
is now focused on you
and your world--
- [Gary] Not true.
It's all listening.
- What's shift?
- [Gary] Nothing shifted.
- Nothing shifted?
Think about what you just said.
Let's break it down #AskGaryVee
is completely predicated on me
listening to you first.
No, it's true.
- That's not the sense I get.
I've been
following you for a while.
We've communicated
with each other.
- [Gary] Yes.
- We follow each
other on Twitter.
- [Gary] Yes, yep.
- I felt a shift and the shift was
very much it's all about you.--
- [Gary] Yep, yes.
- to a little bit
it's all about me.
- [Gary] Yeah.
Well then, I'm doing a poor job.
I totally understand
because how could I argue
that if that's what you feel.
So maybe my bad job was the
tactic of it being #AskGaryVee
instead of ask everybody, right,
may be it's something like that.
I don't know man I've never felt
like I've been able to provide
more value than
I'm doing right now.
May be the positioning. May
be what's going on with the
positioning is throwing it off
but I've never been at the scale
of engagement so Thank You
Economy I really feel like this
is absolutely evolution of it
because instead of me putting
out content that I want to put
out its completely predicated on
everybody else. Right?
I'm answering and
engaging more than I ever have.
I'm producing more
about myself than ever
and maybe
that's the shift. Right?
I've never had DRock following
me around so I have empathy for
where you're going with it.
- And by the way, the reason I
ask is a lot of people ask me
this whole question about how do
you shift the focus from being
in the spotlight and
being a self promoter--
- [Gary] Yes.
- to actually standing
for something.
Being a cause--
- [Gary] Yes.
- Being someone who's out there
in the world trying to push a
movement forward.
Push something forward.
- [Gary] Yes. Yes.
- And I've been asked
that same question--
- [Gary] Yes.
And so you're worried that I'm
going in the wrong direction?
I'm asking. By the way,
I'm a big boy. I respect.
- [Daniel] A, I was wondering if
there was a deliberate shift,--
- Yeah.
- [Daniel] B, I was wondering
whether, like, I've worked with
some of the biggest
speakers in the world--
- Okay.
- [Daniel] there's
always a shift,
- Okay.
- [Daniel] where they
basically go from being
completely humble about--
- Yeah.
- [Daniel] to that
you're in the zone
In that area of
300 people showing up
people queueing up
down to the thing.
- Dude, I think
it's a great question.
I think it's a
very fair question.
Keep the mic because
we're still jamming.
I think that number one, I've
always been egotistical and
humble at the same time.
I built a $65 million business
as a kid before I came out and
did anything I had plenty of
ego before I even did that.
I never worry about
this and I'll explain why.
I always know what my intent is.
I only think that the giving has
exploded more of the attention
because I'm doing even better.
I think the reason there's more
of this going on is because I've
done it better with #AskGaryVee
'cause I've given more than
I used to, believe it or not,
because I created structure
around the giving.
I so much have empathy for
where you're going,
I'm not too worried about it
because all those people that
you're talking about I don't think
they go and spent 3 1/2 hours
in the corner.
You know? I don't.
- When things blow up when
things go absolutely the way
they've gone for you
and it goes exponential,--
- [Gary] Yes.
- how do you then
find your center?
- I feel centered man.
I think it depends
what one cares about.
Right?
For example, I wish we really
deeply knew each other because
if you lived in my brain you
would be flabbergasted by how
much money I leave on the table.
If my CFO was sitting here it's
so insane how people that are
closer to me who actually have
access like when DRock was a fan
and wanted to make a video
versus DRock today who has
(censored) access, right?
DRock likes me so much more
because he knows the truths
behind your question.
I can't worry about it
because I know ebbs and flows.
There was an early time in
Web 2.0 when I really had it at
South-by I was one of
two or three people.
Then I decided I needed to build
another business to have the
audacity to talk to people
about business so I got quiet.
If you think about it, for
me, between 11 to 14, right?
Then I was like wait a minute I
really learned a lot let me go
into a Q&amp;A show because when I
was doing keynotes my Q&amp;A part
was where people
really liked it.
Instead of me saying that I want
to talk about social networks
or this stuff let's
see what they want.
Right?
Listen, I know the business
speaker and personal brands too,
I have not made my
money in that environment.
When you go list everybody
you're about to list I've made
way more of my money
building actual businesses.
If my CFO or my accountant were
here they hate that I do this.
They're like you build
businesses. Vayner's gone from
four to 100 million in revenue,
you'll make more money
in a month if you stopped
speaking, stop writing books,
stop doing this.
I don't want to.
I like this.
I do this more out of the vanity
of I like the interaction and I
like the feeling that it feels
to be loved like this because my
mom loved me so much.
Again, it's very important to
me, the other big speakers don't
have businesses that are
built to make money
not off that audience.
I don't want anything from you.
(applause)
It's a big deal. Right?
It's a big (censored) point.
Everybody else you're about
the name, they want his money,
I don't.
Every three years I say can
you buy something for 18 bucks?
And even then if he doesn't do
you know what it feels like to
answer emails at three in the
morning, all day engage, put out
the content I know you do and
then when you start promoting
for five or six weeks
an $18 book
not a $25,000 a year mastermind.
Not an $800 e-book.
But an $18 book and then
somebody comments like
GaryVee you're a little
much on promotion.
I'm like (censored), really?
And then I get crazy because I'm
(censored) crazy and I'll click
that person and I'll go look
and this (censored) is paying
some guy $10,000 to be
his (censored) coach.
Who's a (censored) loser.
Got it?
And I appreciate you and the
reason why wanted to jam
was in dialogue when we get that
punchline it becomes important.
And I appreciate you
giving me that feedback.
For me to be all about me for
them, the right move is to then
take money from them.
That's the move you're referring
to in that speaker world.
That's what they try to do.
They try to monetize
their audience, I'm not.
Right? I'm looking for legacy.
I'm looking for legacy.
I want their
emails in nine years.
That's what gets me off.
I've made a lot of money.
I've made a lot
of money already.
Money is not driving me.
I'm going to get that.
I did that before I
came onto the scene,
I'll get that when I quiet.
I like the interaction.
I like the legacy.
I like the feeling.
I like the people liking me.
I've got that vanity, for sure.
But don't let that vanity
confuse that I'm trying to do
something wrong
and take the dollars
and that's a different thing.
The reason I never worry about,
of course, it's all about me and
it's equally all about you
and I think that the way people
consume me is a reflection of
where they're at with themselves
and that's how I
use it to navigate.
You know?
(applause)
Thanks buddy. That's it?
Can I get one more?
- We can do one more.
- We can do one more, Rob.
We can do one more.
Thank you brother.
This beautiful lady right here.
There we go.
You don't call her a woman?
What do you mean what the hell?
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
- Hey Gary.
- [Gary] Real quick,
this woman bullshit.
Did you see that woman?
That's a woman, she asked.
Yeah, don't come
with that bullshit.
- [Woman in front row]
Beg my pardon,
mostly guys here tonight.
- [Gary] Well (censored), what
do you want me to force people
to walk in here?
Listen let's go on the street.
Listen, I wish this whole
room was (censored) women.
(audience laughter)
Go ahead.
- Gary, we love you.
We've been following you for
a long, long time since
Wine Library so thank you,--
- [Gary] Thank you.
- for being our virtual
coach for the last 8, 9 years.
Thank you.
- [Gary] You're welcome
and you know what the
total price of that was?
Zero (censored) dollars.
(laughter)
- [Woman] We have successful
franchise businesses in the UK.
Women focused, 40-plus
women, diet, fitness, wellness.
We want to break into the U.S.
We need some tips,
we need some help,
we need some ideas
to drive it forward.
- [Woman 2] How do we do it?
How do we get into the U.S.?
We're great in the UK.
We're doing wonderful work,--
- Okay.
- [Woman 2] we're at
the top of the field but
how do we get into the U.S.?
- I love that.
No, no, I love it, I love it.
I'm using bloody this week too.
I'm like holy shit.
I love it. I love it.
Tell me what the business is?
- [Woman] Mine's a
diet and fitness,
nutrition, wellness franchise.
- Okay.
And so what does that mean?
- [Woman] It means it's a club.
It's a diet club.
Kind of Weight Watchers,--
- Okay.
- [Woman] mixed with an
exercise element as well.
- [Woman 2] And Paleo.
More paleo concepts in there.
- Got it.
And so you're looking
for people to buy into
your franchise and sell?
- [Woman] Yeah.
In the U.S.
- [Gary] And so what
did you do in the UK?
- Social media, speaking,
working, we went out, database
the whole thing that you say.
- [Gary] Okay. So what's the
difference between the US?
- [Woman] It's a
different mindset.
Different mentality.
- [Woman 2] I
think it is, it is.
- Okay.
(audience laughter)
- [Woman 2] It is.
Don't tell me it isn't.
- Let's talk about it.
Listen, we're here for a reason.
- [Woman 2] Do you have
people saying how do I get into
the bloody USA?
- I'm spending all my time
trying to figure out how I'm
going to come to
the bloody UK, right?
So I'm with you.
They're all different and
there's context, I respect that.
Here's my question.
My question is have you tried
yet to recruit for US consumers?
- [Woman] Yeah, we have.
But legality is very different
so contracts and legal stuff is
very different in the
U.S. than it is UK.
That's fine, we can deal
with that but with Facebook
marketing, social media
marketing do we need to be
targeting different
people, different elements--
- [Gary] Have you done it?
- No.
- Well, that's
the first problem.
(audience laughter)
And this is what I'm
going down this path.
You're doing classic non-US
business coming to US mentality.
This is where I'm going.
Let me explain.
There is inferiority complex
to businesses that are based
outside of the US when they come
to the US because people know
the US is a very big market,
it's a very competitive market,
and I always tell my
entrepreneur friends of all
shapes and sizes that when you
come to the US if you're good
enough you're going to win.
Right?
The reason I was going down the
path of my questions is you've
already made assumptions
without actually doing it.
You have.
- [Woman] Do you think we
need to change the whole
face of the business?
- No I do not.
- [Woman] Do we
need a new website?
- Here's some good news I have
no fucking idea but you first
got a try and figure out
if you have to do that.
That's what I was able to sense.
You have to go first
execute your model
before psyching yourself out
that your model won't work
there because it's different.
That's what you've done.
Well then you don't know but
you need to run that blueprint.
Everybody is telling me Gary you
got a run of different blueprint
in the UK.
I'm like (censored) you.
I'm going to run my blueprint.
Now, if the market says
(censored) you back
then I'll adjust.
- [Woman] So Gary, why are
people saying that to you?
Why do you need to do
a different blueprint
in the UK than the U.S.?
- Well, they say that in the UK,
American businesses come and
they're a little too American
and you got to make sure you
have your humility and I'm like
that's a problem because I'm too
American for Americans.
(audience laughter)
Classic stuff like that.
It's different. This is
what everybody does.
Everybody does it because it
comes from a sense of pride.
Americans are gonna tell you
is different because they're
prideful that
America is so competitive.
It's not different, you
just have to be good.
- [Woman 2] So we just
need to be bloody brave?
- Bloody brave.
You know what's funny--
- And just go do it.
- [Gary] Forget about
that first you just do it.
- [Woman 2] Yeah, just do it.
- You don't even
have to be brave.
You just have to do it so you
can taste it to see what
and how you need to adjust.
- [Woman 2] Yeah, we're doing
it here and we're cool
so do it there.
- I think so.
- [Woman 2] Okay.
(audience cheers)
- Thank you.
All right that's
it for this part.
London thank you so much.
Let's clap it out for each other
and each other's questions.
(applause and cheering)
Question of the day:
What English Premier League
team should I support?
(audience yelling)
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(applause)
Louder.
(hip hop music)